also here tonight victor davis hanson
senior fellow at the hoover institution
victor we should have seen this coming
they put joe in charge withdrawing
american troops from iraq
remember that
three years later we're back when isis
took over
we're getting the same thing we're going
to have to go back to rescue people
we're going to go back probably to have
to hit al qaeda or isis or the taliban
except these guys are going to be armed
to the teeth with night vision goggles
howitzers humvees and us drones
yeah joe biden talks so tough remember
he said he took a chain to corn pop and
he was going to take donald trump behind
the gym and beat him up
but i wish he was half as tough with the
taliban he keeps saying august 31st
august 31st august 31st there's only one
deadline and that's when all of our
people that need to come out are out and
there is no other alternative otherwise
jesse we're going to have a thousand bo
bergdahl scenarios coming out popping up
for the next six months
we know how that worked out and let's be
clear about joe biden
our army was never defeated in the field
by the taliban he surrendered and then
he ordered them to flee we haven't done
that before and then
then he said all the contractors all the
people who fed us all the people who
serviced our equipment
we're going to leave you there and we're
going to pull out the military first
they're going to flee and leave you to
your own fortunes
and then he said
we've never done this before we're going
to leave 70 million
70 billion dollars worth of equipment
and we're going to end up fighting
people that look like us and are armed
like us over the next few months he
gives us all the information that we
don't want to know about and none that
we do it remind me if if the mayor of
chicago had said we had a good saturday
night last weekend we had 10 000 people
that were not killed
but she doesn't tell us how many were we
want to know how many people are left
there and how they're going to get out
not how many people you've taken out or
nato's taken out or any of them now and
he can't do that he won't say and i
think people are very patient
but they're so bewildered because this
has never happened in american history
and they think
what's going on and now they're getting
angry
and i don't think he has any under
any idea joe biden does how angry people
are going to get he has not connected
with the american people he is totally
emotionally detached from the country
and from the images that we're seeing on
the screen i had people all weekend come
up to me waters can you believe this
waters can i haven't had that happen in
you know since the election
and now people are coming up to me
they're just disgusted
and it's the images are seared into the
brains of people watching you can't hide
this this isn't like a debt ceiling
debacle this isn't irs targeting this
isn't your typical washington drama this
is real life and people don't like to
watch these images they don't like to
hear the voices of stranded americans
begging crying for the
commander-in-chief to save them and the
commander-in-chief comes out and says
you know what taliban's kind of making
it tough you know we've been talking to
the taliban you know we talked to him
all day you know we've been talking to
the taliban we don't want to hear that
we want to hear let's get these guys out
and he's just he's not meeting the
moment
no i mean everybody you talk to they say
if we wanted to screw this up and
endanger americans what else would we
have done they can't even imagine well i
guess we would have surrendered to the
enemy and then we would have been
humiliated then we would have let the
enemy that never defeat us determine how
we flee and then we would give them 70
billion dollars but that wouldn't be
enough they wanted they want to set the
deadline themselves and we would take
the military out and let this they can't
come up in their wildest dreams with
anything more humiliating or shameful or
dangerous so they're bewildered all of
us are bewildered we're like it's a bad
dream we haven't woken up we hope it's a
dream but it's reality
it's not joe biden's reality just tell
joe corn pops over there and then he'll
just get tough and he'll start taking
the fight to the taliban victor
davis-hanson
thanks for joining prime time hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else